I'm Brian Hill and we're playing start
been stuck I'm gonna be giving the
category and I got a big one start one a
bench and one to cook
I've been Friday Night Lights because I
like the show better than a movie
cut rude and you know I got a start I
wanna I want my read I start telepathy I
start to love it'd be pretty cool to
know what people thinking you know
especially in a quiet room super
strength overrated I go cut super
strength bench super street dang hi I'm
starting Rick and Morty I've been on
Rick and Morty I can't wait to finish
season four
I'm gonna cut South Park I'm gonna bend
spongebob I can't just let go as far as
I like that
favorite spongebob episode when
Squidward finally ate at the krabby
patty yeah that he got fat man spongebob
face when he finally called him funny
and that ain't easy but I'm gonna start
piecing piece of my favorite food of
course that dippin and wings though
that's hard I'm gonna cut the dip bench
the wings I can't get rid of the wind
you need the wings at the party man we
cut man today put my speed up from 88
I'm faster than free we gonna [ __ ] call
of duty I'll barely play that Grand
Theft Auto you can do anything so we
starting that that's hard but I'll
probably start Sarina just because you
know what she doing is crazy nobody ever
done that I'm gonna bench Tigra because
like I said with Sarina you know they
undisputed number one Tom Brady I feel
like eating a more quarterback all the
time but you can still argue that so I'm
gonna cut it I mean it's a lotta is a
lot of great quarterbacks to play this
game so it's a good argument but the
other two you know they are disputed I'm
barely listening to Jay Z so I'm gonna
cut the blueprint
the bench is getting rich or die trying'
and you know we starting the car the
three baby Weezy I'm Brian and this is
start best gut